good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight is joe biden's first day
in office
and you know what that means cnn can
finally take that covet death ticker off
the screen there's no reason for it now
it's not like you can blame joe biden
for some chinese virus that escaped from
a lab and wuhan
that wouldn't be fair come on now cnn
dutifully removed it this morning
covet deaths settle down america it's
just a bad flu season
joe biden apparently agrees he and his
family were photographed in washington
last night without masks
but not a big deal explained his flak
today quote he was celebrating a
historic day in our country
we have bigger things to worry about
okay
makes sense by the way what are those
bigger things that joe biden
is worrying about well since this
happens to be joe biden's maiden day on
the job we can actually answer that
question with some specificity
you can tell what people care most about
but what's at the top of their to-do
lists
at the top of joe biden's to-do list
were two things opening the borders
and crushing our country's last
remaining independent economic sector
so that's what he's doing first biden
signed an executive order revoking the
permit for the keystone xl pipeline
no matter how you feel about fossil fuel
and if you drive a car or fly on
airplanes or use the hospital or
enjoy electricity you might want to
think carefully about how you feel about
fossil fuel
there is no question and there's no
getting around the economic effect of
this decision
millions of americans don't have jobs
right now
but with a single shaky signature joe
biden just put another
11 000 people out of work in this
country just like that
but he wasn't done biden also instructed
the department of homeland security to
halt deportations of illegal aliens
and when we say illegal aliens and by
the way pretty soon we won't be allowed
to say illegal aliens because it'll be
hate speech and therefore illegal
but tonight when we say illegal aliens
we mean millions
of illegal aliens not just the countless
undocumented americans that joe biden
tells us are busy curing cancer winning
nobel prizes
and in general being a lot more
impressive than you have ever been
but this doesn't apply simply to them
biden's orders
also includes non-nobel prize-winning
illegal aliens that means
criminals rapists murderers other people
who are dangerous to you and me
so the message is clear if you break our
laws to get here and commit violent
felonies once you arrive sometimes
against american citizens
joe biden will reward you with blanket
amnesty
and just to show how much he means it
joe biden will do that on his very first
day
as president it's a pretty strong
straight statement
so why wouldn't seeing that statement
every poor person in the world sneak
into
america well of course they would you
would we would
and they will increasing the size of
america's population is the whole point
of the exercise and joe biden himself
explained that
when he first started running for
president we could afford
to take in a heartbeat another two
million people
the idea that a country of 330 million
people
cannot absorb people who are in
desperate need and who are justifiably
fleeing
oppression is absolutely bizarre
absolutely bizarre i would also move to
increase the total number of immigrants
able to come to the united states
we can afford to take another two
million people in a heartbeat
explain joe biden really can we we're
that rich a country
are we getting a lot richer have you
done the math on that mr president how
exactly did you
calculate those numbers can we see them
unfortunately we can't see those numbers
joe biden's not a numbers guy
joe biden is all heart closer to a
religious leader than an accountant
and that's why in his first address from
the oval office joe biden unveiled a
bust of cesar chavez
the famed left-wing labor leader who led
the great pickers union in california in
the 60s and 70s
our easily impressed friends in the
media were needless to say
easily impressed by this they saw it as
a gesture of racial solidarity or
something
biden cesar chavez bust in the oval
signals a new era for latinos
activist hope read a totally real
headline in the washington post
it's all pretty hilarious if you know
anything about cesar chavez chavez the
man not the bronze image in the oval
office
the real cesar chavez passionately hated
illegal immigration
he said so all the time he never stopped
saying it
immigration lowers the wages of american
workers that's the whole point of it of
course
cesar chavez wasn't well educated but he
was not stupid
he understood exactly what was going on
he was enraged by the efforts to open
our border with mexico he knew it was
another corporate scam posing as a human
rights imperative we must
right when the government refused to
secure the border cesar chavez's men did
it themselves
in the winter of 1979 look it up members
of chavez's union the united fruit
workers formed what they called a human
wetline
as in [ __ ] their word not ours across
the southern desert and brutally
assaulted mexican nationals trying to
come north for work
cesar chavez's men hit them with chains
that happened for real that's the guy
joe biden just told us he reveres
no one believes that no one who knows
anything no one in central america
believes that
believes joe biden really has any idea
who cesar chavez was
all they know is that amnesty has been
announced so of course they're coming
why wouldn't they
what do you want for your people what i
want for my people i just want
patient and pest that we can get to the
u.s because they're having a new
president
where's biden he's going to help all of
us he's given us
a hundred days to get to the u.s and
give us legal mental paper
so we can get a better life for our kids
and family
100 days they know the details are ready
better than most americans do
he's going to help all of us and they're
right
all of us includes people like luciano
dominguez trejo he was arrested in this
country for sexually assaulting a minor
thanks to joe biden he gets to stay here
so does juan hernandez rodriguez
rodriguez is a self-described
gang member with convictions for felony
grand theft and burglary
he's been ordered removed from this
country five separate times
but he's still here now he's staying so
is itancio oreno
gutierrez another convicted gang member
convicted of felony burglary
also luis rodriguez jacabo convicted of
manslaughter
santos maria won't be going anywhere
either he was also convicted of
manslaughter along with armed robbery
when joe biden tells you the real threat
to our country comes from within
these are definitely not the people he's
talking about of course he's talking
about
you he's certainly not talking about
fernando de jesus lopez garcia
like millions of people in california
lopez garcia is living in this country
illegally he's been arrested multiple
times for
violent crimes but the state of
california has allowed him to stay in
order not to seem racist
then finally inevitably in november
this happened
san jose transformed into a horrific
crime scene in what the mayor says was a
preventable tragedy
multiple system failures led to this
moment
police say fernando lopez an
undocumented transient used a knife to
stab
five people at grace baptist church
which was serving as a homeless shelter
two homeless people a man and a woman
were killed two other transients and a
church volunteer were wounded
lopez had been deported three times and
has a history of domestic violence
arrests
officials said he should not have been
out on the streets
it was a failure of multiple systems no
it wasn't our systems work
we just don't use them it was a failure
of will
it was our country perverted by bad
ideas self-destructive suicidal ideas
which seem to have taken hold among the
people in charge
immigration law exists to keep things
like the things you just saw from
happening
in a typical hundred day period last
year for example
federal ice agents removed 46 800
immigrants with criminal convictions or
pending criminal charges
that's a lot of people 46 000 now
they're all staying
and that's fine with joe biden it's not
like they're trying to operate a
restaurant in new jersey during
quarantine or
walk through a park without a mask on
they're not criminals they're civil
rights heroes
one thing for certain they're definitely
not aliens and that's another change we
learned about this week
henceforth the totally moderate and not
at all radical by the administration
demands that federal agencies refer to
illegal aliens as quote non-citizens
now that's less precise obviously but
it's way less racist so it's better
joe biden himself is going to try to
remember this less than a year ago he
kept forgetting was still using the
wrong term
there are certain things you can not
deport an undocumented
alien for an undocumented person four
undocumented alien oh sorry undocumented
person
that was close at 78 joe biden narrowly
avoided a moment of white supremacy on
television
but rest assured joe biden is careful
with his language
he knows in the name of unity people
should not be allowed to use certain
words or have certain thoughts
everyone must think exactly the same
thing all the time
now that seems like a mandatory
conformity to you
and terrifying no it's unity
and that's why on the bide
administration's website you can now
select your preferred pronouns
as you fill out the contact form bigotry
has met its defeat on the white house
website hallelujah
we do have one nagging question though
what exactly
is the point of all of this these things
that have been done in the last 24 hours
well any of these changes these bigger
things that joe biden has enacted on his
very first day in office
actually help any living american
we're pretty sure the pronoun thing will
appeal to whatever tiny group of deluded
unhappy people
still believe that destroying nature's
gender roles is a form of liberation
talk about a war on nature so they're
very excited congrats to them but what
about everyone else
how for example does amnesty and the
waves of mass illegal immigration that
inevitably will follow
make this a better more united country
you're not supposed to ask that question
but it's totally fair the rest of us
live
here we have a right to know how does
this make
our country better and more united
anyone who tries to answer that question
not that anyone has so far but anyone
who does
should first have to explain whatever
happened to the state of california
the state with the most illegal
immigration by far how exactly in the
course of a single generation did the
best state in the union become the worst
state
how did the place that so many americans
desperately wanted to move to
become the place that millions of
americans are fleeing
honestly what's the answer to that
question
no one in the media asked today but
during the briefing the question of
immigration did come up
and here's how the new white house press
secretary responded to it
immigration we consider as part of
racial equity and part of
which is a broad issue but that's how
the president has spoken about that
crisis over the past several months and
clearly it is an enormous priority to
him
so there you go that's the answer i
guess
the byte administration's immigration
plan is not
designed to improve the united states of
america
it's not intended to make americans
happier or richer
or more secure or more united
now you might think those would be the
aims of every government policy
always but no not in this case the point
of joe biden's immigration
plan is quote racial equity
now we've got to be completely honest
with you and say that we're not exactly
sure what that means
the point is racial equity unfortunately
nobody asked in the coming weeks we're
going to do our best to find out since
this is a
government policy it matters and we have
a right to know
but as of tonight it sounds a lot like
punishment
mass immigration explains joe biden
isn't something that will make your life
better
it's something you deserve